this is Susan Susan loves to bike while
out for a ride she falls and breaks her
arm special cells called neurons send a
signal through the spinal cord to the
brain which interprets the signal as
pain
Susan understands the pain means she
needs to go to the hospital and her body
is equipped for survival helping her not
to panic so she can seek help
many of her neurons are covered in
proteins called opioid receptors these
receptors act like a brake to slow down
the neurons ability to send pain signals
when injured her body releases natural
painkillers called endorphins like a key
in a lock endorphins activate opioid
receptors slowing down the pain signal
and preventing a panic Susan gets
treated for the broken bone but three
months later her arm still hurts and now
that pain is making her feel depressed
and anxious so her doctor prescribes an
opioid painkiller there are many
different opioids but they all share a
chemical similarity to our own
endorphins this allows them to bind to
the same opioid receptors and stop pain
signals but that's not all they do
deep inside Susan's brain is a region
called the ventral tegmental area or VTA
for short the VTA is full of neurons
that produce a chemical called dopamine
when something good happens dopamine is
released giving Susan a feeling of
pleasure this helps teach her brain to
keep seeking out good things
to keep dopamine neurons in check
inhibitory neurons keep the brakes on
until something good comes along just
like the pain neuron these neurons are
covered in opioid receptors when Susan
takes the painkiller prescribed by her
doctor the opioid receptors turn off the
inhibitory neurons and release the brake
on the dopamine neurons the rush of
dopamine temporarily eliminates Susan's
depression and anxiety and she feels
relief calmness and even euphoria as
Susan continues to take the painkillers
her brain responds by trying to regain
its balance her inhibitory neurons work
extra hard even when the opioid
receptors are activated and it becomes
harder and harder for her dopamine
neurons to release dopamine Susan finds
that she needs to increase her dose of
painkillers in order to feel comfortable
this is called tolerance eventually
Susan's pills run out inhibitory neurons
that have been working overtime or let
loose clamping down on those dopamine
neurons and shutting them off almost
completely now not only is Susan in pain
but the depression and anxiety come back
on top of that Susan feels ravaged by an
inescapable physical sickness far worse
than any flu Susan's body is going
through withdrawal
most people who take opioids for a long
time tend to experience some withdrawal
but they can still stop taking the pills
and return to normal but for people like
Susan it's not so easy her genetics in
the environment she grew up and put her
at a higher risk for addiction her
withdrawal symptoms aren't just
unpleasant
they're unbearable Susan thinks the only
way to feel normal is to find more
opioids and this is how the cycle of
opioid addiction emerges driven by a
brain trying to regain its balance but
there is hope for Susan though the road
to recovery can be challenging and there
may be setbacks treatment can retrain
Susan's brain
with the help of medication and therapy
Susan finds pleasure in her life once
again
[Music]
you